good morning believe nation today's
message is change life over to you Tim
people from me and playing sports it's
not being focused on winning or losing a
game because yeah you want to be the
best you want to try to win super hands
or make it to the big leagues and all
these things but you want to at the end
of the day be more than just a sport
you're trying to play you want to France
in that sport if all you do if all I
ever did was win or loose at a game I
don't really look at my life as a lot of
significance but if I can transcend that
sport to inspire people to put a smile
on people's faces to encourage people to
make it different to change one person's
life or a million people's lives then I
would consider that significance and
meaning the goal is not to be famous the
goals not to have money in your bank
account the goals not to have with the
world defines the success the goal is to
change life so what do you think I think
it resonates true where you're you're
trying to doing whatever position you
wasn't you're doing something socially
or quark but you want to know see people
around you that look up to you that you
inspire and take them over the wing and
never be too tired to give people or
more advice be there for them a little
more to move away from your selfishness
you know I'm having a bad day or I need
to get this done and be there for unless
your team and your friends and your
family yeah I think people get into
things often for the wrong reasons I
think a lot of people start a YouTube
channel because they want to be YouTube
famous and they're only trying to get a
million subscribers I think a lot of
people start a business just trying to
get rich you know they look at the
forbes magazine of the top hundred hot
companies to start right now make a lot
of money and then they get into and to
realize that it's a lot harder than they
thought it was going to be you have to
enjoy the process you have to enjoy the
work that people who winter on a mission
they want to make the world better
somehow whether that's through your
youtube channel through your business
through your salsa dancing whatever it
is you're on a mission that is much more
than just achieving end result if you're
only chasing the result you're never
going to get there we can join the
process
success will be yours so the question
the day today is have you been there for
someone else have you been there for
someone else today I like it leave it in
the comments below we will join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Liang side mom up or
pronounce it okay thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word I really really really appreciate
it and I hope you're enjoying the
reading so thank you guys so much for
watching we believe in you i hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
i will see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot I was pressing I think
in general you you really should try to
live your life without regrets and if
you and if you are really set on
starting a particular company even if
you know that you could go be employing
number 30 at Airbnb and everybody is
already going like this and you'd have
more of an impact but you're going to
regret for the rest of your life not
starting this particular company because
you're so in love with it you might
decide to do that however i think this
other thing like making an impact on
whatever you do is sort of the
satisfying thing in life in professional
life and so i think most people find
that their job satisfaction like goes up
with with the impact they have on their
company or the world or whatever and if
you start a company that is you know a
mild success or join a company that's a
huge success you probably have more of
an impact in the latter case thing which
attracted me to google and to Internet
in general is that it's a great
equalizer right and so to me always
being struck by the fact that Google
search work the same mm-hmm it's as long
as you had access to computer with
connectivity give it a rule okayed
anywhere or if you were a professor at
Stanford or Harvard
and and to me you know I want Google to
strive to push to do that not just build
technology for a certain segments right
for me it's it matters that you know we
drive technology as an equalizing force
as an enabler to everyone around the
world